yeah I lost my dad and um what happened
was my mom called me and she goes on
daddy he I was at I was at a hot dog
place I love hot dogs I love Chicago and
hot dogs cuz of the peppers and uh they
add extra like were you about to order
the hot dog when you heard this message
or you know I had the hot dog in my hand
okay and I didn't even eat it I go what
and I just didn't eat it and then I went
into panic next yeah it was not even a
panic it was more of a um yeah it was a
shock numb yeah it's like when I was
molested when I was a kid by a guy with
Down syndrome it's true story is your
story he used to give you candy yeah my
point is is that it's the same feeling
of just like you it's almost dreamy and
otherworldly it's not good it's not a
good feeling but it's like what the [ __ ]
this is like you know you you know and
so I called my brother Steve my
brother's freaking out and we just
booked the flight and then but you know
I hadn't been going to a meetings in
four years at 17 years of sobriety and
then next thing I know I'm at a place
called um I might have I might have
[ __ ] it weed dispensary I want to say
the name right and I'm in line to get
weed
17 years of being sober I don't know how
I got there bro
I was going home and I just pulled it
was called urban freeze grape
establishment great weed that's where
you got your weed that's right yeah and
smoked weed in 17 years so I ordered
what I bought was I bought hey do you
have gummies so I got like 15 packets of
gummies and this is how alcoholic my
brain is I and I because I didn't want
to tell my brother or my girlfriend or
my mom that I relapsed so I went to CVS
and I got melatonin melatonin gummy you
know um candy know you can get melatonin
ones at the sleep sleep there right and
they're shaped like they're gummy bears
so you put them all in there but I took
all the I dumped that and I put all the
weed ones in there sure and so when I
was packing to go um that's what I had
and were they really like today
everything they said there's a most
strongest one I don't know 10 milligrams
Pisa but oh so evident after not getting
high for over 17 years you know I took
one and I just completely got almost way
too high